our following guest is remembered for
winning Super Bowl 40 as a member of the
Pittsburgh Steelers and losing a race to
me before Super Bowl 43 he was a member
of the 1990 Notre Dame team that could
have won a national title but somebody
got called for clipping on rocket
Ishmael's return sorry about that
although many view him is a Hall of Fame
football player I view him as a failed
professional bowler please welcome the
lovely and talented Jerome hi bussy how
you doing hey done and this is what you
call a friend that's how friends treat
friends they give him a little bit of
grief true the last time I had you and I
promised I'd never bring up that foot
race again trust me the foot race I feel
so bad for you know you were 36 at the
time he is I had on for dress shoes the
whole deal this guy had on running shoes
the whole deal he warmed up before he
was ready to go head start okay I didn't
know how fast he was already okay I give
you that but we wasn't side-by-side
running start
he ended up keeping his head start
almost I cut into it a little bit do you
think Dungey is a liar yes or no listen
he didn't see the angle the full angle
he wasn't at the finish line he was at
the starting race you remember Tony all
that just started a race Tony does not
lie right Tony Dungy does not lie not
gonna say I'm sure he's told Jordan
appear
I'm sure he's telling it
it's great to see it it's great to see
we ran now what was your 40 my 40 uh at
what point because when I was dragged
fastest my fastest I was i weighed 252
and i ran at 4 or 5 - okay that's good
that's pretty fast yeah that's very
impressive yeah you caught me 20 years
later no I caught you at you were 30 you
just retired I was beat up though isn't
that the reason why you retired is
because I beat you like no you beat me
after our retired yeah and after I had
shut it down and I had you know won a
Super Bowl in my hometown and all that
came with that and they had a lot of fun
and it wasn't training and I was hurting
a little bit too physically my body was
bitten out naturally dentally physically
my body was beat up which is why I'm
here so you remember that okay
would you have 3,400 carries yeah over
3,000 yeah is there one that still hurts
one carry via no like gonna let you know
I'm just curious cuz you okay you gave
it more than you got it the only only
carry I love to have back was the fumble
against Indianapolis if I if that was
one carry out to have back and all the
reason I want that carry back is because
now every time I go anywhere I'm in
Airport I'm like are you serious my
whole career you remember that moment I
fumble and it's like that's the only
carry anybody remember that I was a Hall
of Fame running back but they can't
remember any carries except the one that
I fumbled you had to be exact
3479 carries people remember that one
one carry what happened on that play
it's real simple
I try to get skinny which is the first
problem right explain
how you getting skinny is really kind of
turning sideways in the hole right and
so the whole was there I gotta get
skinny and the linebacker came right
across and as I had the ball here he
came right across because I took usually
you go here I turn here exposing the
ball and he had a perfect shot hit me
the ball bounced up in the air and
luckily been saved a day for me but it
could have been a you know I hate to say
you know another guy's name but a Bill
Buckner type moment because yes had he
had that we lost that game that would
have been the end of my career and
that's that's definitely all oh
everything everybody will talk about you
would even be talking about that you
know what I might be a little more
sensitive to it if you fumbled and you
guys didn't get to the Super Bowl you
might yeah I've been around you know not
that terrible know I'm close but not
know I would have been sensitive to that
you know we start to look at running
backs though Jerome and it's kind of
hard to figure out what is great now
because it's a different label to what
is is great like Derek Henry 20 years
ago 15 years ago that's what the NFL was
and we brought back old school a little
bit with the Titans but I don't know
will we see a is that the new thing
possibly that the running back is gonna
be that big physical back or is there
just only one Derek Henry I think what
you're gonna see is teams figuring out
what they have at quarterback and I
think what you have at quarterback is
gonna determine what you need at running
back if you've got a really outstanding
quarterback ie Patrick mahomes then no
you're not going to invest in that
running back because the odds of you
running you know 40 times the games very
slim right so you're gonna you're gonna
put make the investment in the receivers
around your quarterback if you don't
have that superstar quarterback then now
you have to think about how are we going
to be successful in the NFL because it's
not
possible and I think the Tennessee
Titans proved that in this day and age
you can still run the football and win a
football game so I just think the
quarterback position determines because
if Tennessee had a really good
quarterback Henry wouldn't have had the
opportunity to run the football the only
only reason he ran the football so much
this year was because the quarterback
situation deteriorated to the point
where they said we're going to give you
30 carries because we're not sure if we
want to throw the football 30 times and
they saw they had a star and in Henry
and they said okay we're going to keep
it going but then comes the decision at
quarterback now if you go out and try to
go get a you know expensive quarterback
or if you keep ten a hill then you want
to keep your running back if you go out
and try to trade for a star quarterback
then I think you want to let the running
back go but if the Titans would bring in
Tom Brady
are you keeping Derek Henry yes because
one you want to help Tom you don't want
to have to throw it about 40 times right
but you know when he does throw he's
gonna be an accurate pass and make the
right decision and you may be at a
prolong his career maybe a year or two
because you want to give the bulk of the
work to the running backs I know that
you told me this story I hope you didn't
tell it to me in confidence but if you
did it's no longer in confidence you
told me about the Super Bowl Ben
Roethlisberger's first Super Bowl and
how the moment you get ready for the
moment but the moment was too big for
him like you guys the veterans were kind
of calming him down in the huddle what
do you remember about that well it was
it was one of those he wanted to win the
game you know the mean and it's not
that's not uncommon we saw what happened
in Baltimore same situation you had a
quarterback who was having an MVP year
and he wanted to win the game and I and
there were some times in that Baltimore
Ravens playoff game where the quad I
probably should have given the ball to
the running back but instead he wanted
to keep it because he want to have
bigger impact in the game that's that's
normal
for a young quarterback in here but you
got young in this Super Bowl like that
moment but but but these guys are me Ben
was a second-year quarterback yeah so
and you know in Baltimore obviously got
a second-year quarterback so as you get
older you realize that the moment is not
as big and and to Ben's credit he
settled down in that game well it wasn't
so much me talking to him as much as he
was allowing the game to happen you know
I mean when you when you when you go out
there and things aren't going your way
you have to kind of you know reassess
everything and and we had a a veteran
team you know at mean so everybody was
got on the same page and we were fine
yeah it's just you know that moment
where guys throw up before the Super
Bowl yeah
did you know I did it was in my hometown
I was excited this is a big moment but
you gotta remember to I was the I was
the the wrapping paper so to speak
because I wasn't doing the the heavy
lifting running the football and I was
not with the quarterback so I was the
wrapping paper that you tear off and you
get to the good stuff
Myron cope the legendary broadcaster
first called you the bus what did you
think of that nickname so so the story
they heard me be called the bus we went
up to Wisconsin and one of the coaches
at Wisconsin was that Notre Dame and his
brother was tied in on my team and long
story short I'm in the lobby and he says
hey buzzy do one of the coaches my
former coach another name he's and then
Bill Hillgrove and Myron cope we heard
him say it and in that next preseason
game we were playing in Wisconsin
against Green Bay he said
the rest is history pusher nickname
before them well when I was at another
name I had two nicknames I had the bus
but I also had Big Daddy big as a truck
quick as a caddy that's why they call me
Big Daddy
no it was the offensive line the
legendary offensive lineman Joe Moore
who was who approached all those guys at
Pitt and then was that Notre Dame he
came up with that bat little big as the
truck quick as a caddy that's why they
call him Big Daddy Dion's downstairs in
the green room watching did he ever
tackle you but he was so good he was so
fast he waited for me to go by which is
the best way to do it well there's speed
and then there's there's world like
tyree kill you look at here when you go
he's faster than than everybody yes
right Dion had that he had that kind of
speed where he was just faster than
everybody he always tells the story
about when he was trying to tackle Bo
and he was a freshman I think at Florida
State and he said Bo Jackson baptized
him he did that hand on the forehead you
had surgery right spine surgery and new
vasive is the company that you're
working with that explained what
happened and how they've helped you kind
of come so after I retired and we talked
about it I mean I was starting to get
really beat up and I think that was
partially why you you stay with me in
that run that we had because I was I was
in pain and and dealing with some issues
and and it got progressively worse I
started to play golf and I thought that
I was okay but I really wasn't in and
then having kids playing with the kids
my quality of life started to
deteriorate really quickly so I started
to do some research because I knew
I needed a fusion for my back and and I
started I found the right surgery which
was called the X lift surgery and then I
needed to find the right surgeon I found
the right surgeon doctor by the name of
dr. Uribe
he was world-class and I had the surgery
and the benefit of it was that it was
non-invasive so they went in through my
love handles on the side which you know
I got some love handles they put it
through the love handles and and did
everything and now no big scars on the
back but for me the big benefit was the
recovery time instead of eight months it
was three months and I got my life back
and very very thankful and anybody wants
to kind of get a story or my journey
it's online you can go to new vasive
comm slash the bus and read about it but
is it just fine surgery it was just it
was just nobody that was that way they
don't 405 that's what they deal with
that's what they do
I see it's always great to see you thank
you I love your laugh and your good
sport about all of this I think I'll
beat you racing right now I'm healthy
I'm back some time to Train you know
that I've had six knee operations and a
replacement knee so even how recently
have you had that I had the replacement
a year ago but I had had five surgeries
beef you know had five knee surgery and
you stay with me closed relatively I
gave you the Head Start though did I
give you a head start
did I give you a head start
yes or no I can turn off your mic and
then I can complete this story you gave
me a five-yard head start and right you
gave me a five-yard head start we went
50 and Tony Dungy and Bob the legend
Bob Costas journalist they they both
said you actually increased your lead on
bus and they felt bad for you it would
say be nice to you know they were being
nice to you because you would you rather
do not fumble against the Colts or have
beaten me in a race I love you
Thank You bus a jury badass the bus for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]